what's up believe nation welcome to
another hangout super pumped to be here
I am making a commitment to every
Thursday try to be here for you answer
your questions either in an AMA format
or with a guest 11 o'clock Eastern what
I'm always aiming for so here we go this
is AMA number 11 you guys have an
important question ask me put it in the
chat and I will answer and part of why I
do this is I kind of wish I had this
when I was younger somebody that you
know maybe I looked up to or I want to
ask a question of and it's so accessible
now and so I love it and I want to be
here for you and let's get through some
questions I love everybody joining in
guys as the questions come in again when
you tag me it's a lot easier to see the
questions and hit my screen so let's get
going
you are stronger than you think how do
you get past that first step I really
want to get started interact with people
but I can't even begin to record a video
or gather info how do you convince
yourself to do something new you are
stronger than you think the answer is in
your name there - I love it
make the first step smaller whatever
that first step is that you want to do
just make it smaller I think it's so so
so so important I think too often we
have these big dreams which is awesome
and you need the big dreams that will
lead you towards doing something amazing
it's inspiring it's motivating but the
big dream it can also be too big it can
be can be scary can be overwhelming and
then you're worried up whatever that
first perfect step is there is no
perfect first step don't worry about it
and just make it smaller and so whatever
you think your first step is make it
even smaller because once you start
building momentum once you actually take
that first step you realize that wasn't
actually as hard as I thought it would
be and so whether it's making videos or
doing research
put less importance on the first step
the first actual step what you do does
not matter make it smaller and I think
it would I think would really help and
just do something today read your own
name you are stronger than you think you
got this let's go all right next up
Chris Young hey Evan what do you think
why do you think people have such a hard
time taking action
making their dreams come true I think
it's I think it's just part of the human
condition that we don't like venturing
out into the unknown there's it's scary
it's there's risk of failure this risk
of you know feeling fun of somebody else
this risk of losing I think the biggest
thing though is probably just our
environment your environment your
routine your habits keep you doing what
you're doing and if you were surrounded
constantly by people who were more
confident you would get more confidence
if you were surrounded by people who are
constantly alcoholic you would become
alcoholic like it's really really hard
to fight the environment that you're in
if everybody around you is doing
something then you are more likely to
want to do it that's just how it works
and so what most people do is they just
fall into their environment they don't
try to consciously make any kind of
decisions or choices or changes and what
I highly encourage you to do is look at
the people in your life who are not
supportive of the path that you want to
go down the people in your life who do
not represent the kinds of people that
you want to be hanging around not not in
terms of the kinds of people but just
the mindset the attitude the belief
system because those belief systems are
toxic to you you don't want them around
you and then substitute with people
ideas resources that lift you up the
biggest change that I felt in the past
five years for me has been my channel by
being around these people on a regular
basis has boosted my confidence has
helped me think bigger it's helped me go
after more ambitious goals of things
that I didn't think we're possible
because all day long I'm around people
who are doing amazing awesome
outstanding things where if you are
around people who hate their job who
hate their life who can't wait to go on
that vacation counting down the days
until quit in time at 5 o'clock it's
really really really difficult to escape
that mindset and be the one person who's
crazy and different than everybody else
and so I think people have a hard time
taking action because you get a bit of
inspiration a motivation you watch one
video you go to one conference you have
one phone call or one conversation to
one meeting and you get inspired and
then you're off taking action but then
the next day you wake up and that's gone
so you need it consistently the
environmental impact has to be
consistent on you I walk in here and
this has an impact on me i watch a video
it has an impact on me I'm making a
video myself on Instagram every morning
has an impact on me and so the the
environment the routine keep you where
you are to change it what do we got we
got a whole bunch of good mornings hey
good morning good morning Wow flying
through ok guys again remember when you
tagged me it's it's so much easier for
me to see Aviv Evan when will you
release an audio book edition of the top
ten of success that is a tough one I
don't know if I ever will it's something
that I've been debating with my team one
because so much of the content is in
other people's words that an audio
version of me saying the words I feel
like is isn't injustice and then it'd be
actually getting the source clips from
the other people and doing it and
there's issues around that and so I
don't know that I don't know if it's
ever gonna happen we're working on the
Kindle version first which should be
soon my team is working on it it's been
it's been insane getting the formatting
down but the audiobook I don't know I
don't know if it's coming you're holding
out for that I don't know I don't know
if it's gonna come but thank you for the
love Zak how do I feel how do I focus
less on the past and more on the present
and future
so I would start with thinking about how
much is the past holding you back how
much is that fear of regret right that
you're living in the past world how much
is that keeping you where you are and
preventing you from where you want to go
I would make it as painful as possible
to make it a be a push forward is if
it's like a dull pain you don't really
feel it enough but if it's a really
sharp pain like this has to stop then
that's when you start making decisions
and changes in your life that's often
what I try to do whenever I have a
little pain in my life I try to make a
future pain so much bigger that then it
forces me to kind of take action to move
forward on it I think the other thing is
you're already aware of it which is
great the key now is to catch it sooner
and so you know how long do you live in
the past for like do you do you live in
it for a day and then you catch it the
next day or can you catch it like an
hour later or can you catch it ten
minutes later like when you're feeling
it
the trick is can you catch it in the
moment and the sooner and sooner and
sooner you can get to that moment where
like here it is it's happening it's
about to happen
I'm not gonna let this happen to have
the awareness in the moment instead of
the awareness the next day makes a huge
difference and then having the courage
to move forward and do it and I think
part of what will help you get the
courage is back to the other question
around the environment you know if you
are around I would I'd be watching as
many videos as I could on a on a daily
basis reading books podcasts whatever
the thing is so that I have a daily hit
from somebody and one individual or
multiple people who have that same
message about not living in the past
because the more you are around these
kinds of people then the more likely you
will stop living in the past like you
are living in the past because you have
learned that behavior from somewhere you
learned it from your parents your liver
different your friends and your
grandparents or somebody around you who
had an influence on you as you grew up
this was their behavior and now you are
modeling it and you've recognized that
this is behavior that you should not be
modeling and so you now you need to
model better behavior right and so you
could think your way through it great
but the modeling and the being in your
awareness and your environment on a
regular basis will make such a big
difference to you actually following
through on it
so those things good luck guys again
when you tag me teach you to see Susan
how do I know if I should go back to
school to learn a new skill set uh so it
depends on where you want to go again
for me it's just like maps to the vision
what is it that you want to do in your
life what's the next step you may not
know where you want to go for the rest
of your life and that's okay you may not
know what 70 or 80 or 90 what you're
gonna look like that's okay but like
what's the next step for you and then I
would ask myself the school help me get
there I have a love-hate relationship
with school
I don't know that I I'm not quite on the
on the side of school sucks and nobody
should go to school but it does
definitely warrant a conversation
whether it's worth the time and
investment or not so for me I didn't get
a lot out of my school experience I went
to University of Toronto it's a great
school the best in my country probably
and I made some contacts it was okay but
from the education perspective I didn't
learn much to become an entrepreneur you
saying you want to go to school to get
the new skills I would strongly debate
that to see whatever the skills are that
you want to learn is school gonna be the
best path for you to get those
experiences or not maybe in some
scientific research or academic fields
but for the most part I think you if
your goal is to get the skills I think
your best bet is to go find the person
who is doing what you want to do and
mentor under them much more than trying
to learn it from a textbook or from
going to class and just think about your
experience in school how much have you
learned growing up through high school
and through whatever education that you
have do you remember everything you
learn in grade 8 history no do you
remember one or two things maybe right
so if you want to learn you could learn
something so much faster just by doing
it then by going to school I think I
think the reason to go to school is for
the connections the contacts the degree
some jobs still really want to see that
degree on the resume and so that can
help you but if you're just trying to go
learn the skills I would strongly
question whether school is the best
place for you to get those skills Tetsu
Tetsu
nori Wow I butchered that name I
apologize Evan how to face change so
here's something that I've been working
on and I posted on Instagram not that
long ago that when change happens to
smile at it when something unexpected
happens and it's usually in it for the
negative right like changes
you don't want it to happen if it's hey
you won a lottery I'm sure you wouldn't
have a hard time with that change its
negative change to smile at it - I try
to see it as this is my opportunity to
show the world what I can do and to show
myself what I can do one of the the
things that I love doing is when a new
YouTube algorithm comes out right like
somebody YouTube's change the algorithm
and all the big channels are complaining
they're gonna leave and they're gonna go
somewhere else
I love it like great this is this is a
chance for me to win right everybody who
won on the old system is now gonna start
losing and now I can win and so every
time that a change happens it's an
opportunity for you to win it's an
opportunity for you to get to the top
and I try to embrace that that part
hasn't been as big a struggle for me the
the struggle that I've had is more when
there's a change to my schedule I'm very
schedule driven I'm very schedule
oriented I love following my schedule
but sometimes things happen 90% of the
time they don't but 10 maybe 10 is even
high but 5 to 10% of the chance
sometimes something happens you know I
have to drive needed to work because
she's sick or Nina is staying home
because she's sick it doesn't really get
sick that often but anyway or just
something happens I have to go pick up
Hayden from school because something
happened you know like it something
changes in my schedule I try to run a no
crisis business and there's very few
things from a business perspective that
has to take my attention away in the
moment but it's more on the personal
side and so when that happens I have a
tendency of letting it cascade into the
rest of my day so it throws off my
morning routine and without my morning
routine it's hard for me to get back on
track and do everything else I don't
need to do and just wait until tomorrow
happens and and that's not a great
strategy now it's only happening 5% of
the time so it's not the end of the
world for me but I want to make that
better and so one of the things that I'm
trying to remind myself of is when that
happens when the change happens when my
schedule is off when some new variable
has been introduced when is some new
change
get excited like it's gonna be harder
today this is my opportunity this is my
opportunity to show myself what I can do
and to show the world what I can do and
so just changing that approach that
anytime change happens it's a good thing
it's a good thing you're gonna get
better you're gonna get stronger you're
gonna you're gonna beat your competition
this is your chance like the change is
the opportunity if things were exactly
the same as they wore a thousand years
ago you would have no shot you have a
chance anytime there's a change that
means you have a even greater chance of
winning and so get excited next Nicholas
hey Evan I want to be an artist but I
don't know how to find or be near other
like-minded people and I can't decide
what kind of art to make music video
design what do I do
okay so in terms of being around
like-minded people first off I would
explore more explore more explore more
explore more I would go to every single
event that is happening in your area in
the greater area like anything that's
within a two-hour drive from you I would
be going out and most of them recognize
that most of them will not work
most meetups will not work most
organizations will not work most
community events will not work you mean
I find anybody there that is gonna be
suitable for you but you will find if
you do it enough you will find one or
two or three or ten people depending on
how consistent you are in doing it and
those one two three ten people will make
all the difference in the world to you
like if that was really your goal I want
to meet like-minded people is so so so
important to me and it's got to be in
person I'm assuming you don't want to do
like online communities the whole that
benefit there you could do it within the
next two months you can find those
people but what is your activity level
like how much are you going out and
trying to do these things if you are out
every single day and every single night
for the next two months you would find
those three five ten people that you
could really really connect with as
like-minded people you just would you
just not putting enough time to go out
to different events and deal with all
the all the rejection all the crap of
most of these things won't work out most
of these events if you find one person
for every three to five events that
you go to you're winning but you don't
want to put in the work to do the four
events where you don't find anybody and
that one event where you only find one
person right and so it's putting in more
work to go off and do it in terms of
finding so for that it's just back to
sorry just back to like how important is
this for you you say it's important you
say it's important it's the one question
that you're asking so it's important now
do your actions match what you say is
important because it was important up
here then it's got to be important in
your actual acting what you are doing
how you're spending you time so you can
find it you can find those five three
five ten people in the next two months
if you're really dedicated yourself to
doing it for the music versus design or
are to figure out the three categories
were try all them like I'm not gonna be
the one to tell you do music and stop
the other ones and in all likelihood
it's gonna be some kind of combination
of the three of them you know if it's
between music and film like it's gonna
be some combination you're gonna make
great music and you're really gonna care
about the film that comes alongside it
or you're gonna make great film and
you're gonna always make sure there's
amazing music musics comes alongside it
so recognize that your genius is going
to be combining all of those things
together into something that only you
can do because if you're only focusing
on music as an example there's always
one gonna be this hole in your heart
that there's this other thing missing
that you weren't able to do that you had
to give up for music but you really want
to do that thing and to you'll never be
the greatest at just music because you
have this other stuff that you want to
do and the people who love music and are
all in on music they're gonna always
crush you you're always gonna be a B or
C player in that field because they have
the passion 100% and you're at like 65%
but when you combine those things
together you create something that
nobody else has ever done before that's
your chance to win that's your that's
your white space that's your chance to
dominate and so I would be exploring as
much as possible with those three things
and trying to figure out how can I make
them all work together to create
something that is unique good luck
Zeb hi Evan I want to make a baking
business do you have any tips on where
to start I love it so just start
honestly like I would I would
what the what the thing is that I love
baking so first off I'll preface this
with I am a terrible baker Nina's
amazing but I suck but say chocolate
chip cookies or let's go with butter
tarts because I love butter tarts I want
I want if you guys have great butter
tarts send them over this way I'm gonna
get hungry just doing this video butter
tarts mmm so you make the best butter
tarts in the world how you start is you
go to different community events there's
a great example that there's a Toronto
bakery called bunner's and they had
gluten-free and vegan baking goods and
now they have two stores or three stores
they have cookbooks they have merch they
have all sorts of stuff but how I first
met them was they were in the basement
of a church selling their stuff and
every week they would go to the basement
of the church and they would sell their
stuff and they would hit up all the
different festivals and all the
different events and it started really
super small and grassroots but they
built a base now I'm not super into
gluten free and dairy free and all that
stuff it doesn't really make a huge
difference for me but people went there
because they loved what she was selling
it tasted amazing which it did and she
built her base right it's like the first
step is don't go spend 50k a hundred K
on getting a huge retail shop and being
locked in for the next five years
because you won't even get that deal
without a huge personal guarantee anyway
the key is you just start so you find
the community events you find the YMCA
you find the church groups you find
everything is happening in your local
area and you start selling and you
create an amazing experience so that
people want to come back your goal is
when you're doing that church bake sale
and somebody tries your amazing butter
tart that they want to buy more they
want to come back right like send me one
of your butter tarts I will eat it and
if I like it I'm gonna order more or I'm
gonna talk about it on my YouTube
channel right so people will come back
they'll tell the friends the one order
more and that's how you you pick up
steam you build a following and then you
can go
maybe take over a part of a retail store
like go to a complementary business that
is not a big bakery but has the same
kind of audience as you and do
consignment or have a little table in
their store just to see just see if it's
work and see if you're getting enough
business from it and then once you've
proven the model then you can go off and
get your own bake shop or you can go
create a YouTube channel you can go
create merch you can go create a
catering business or whatever it is that
you want to eventually build it up and
grow but humble beginnings like the you
that you're gonna take just thinking
about it you could have already built
the business going to different church
groups and different community events
selling your stuff and building your
audience that's how you start and send
me the butter tarts mmm next a Flacco TV
Evan how do you find your passion and
guys I know you know there's a lot
happen in the chat if I didn't get your
question just keep asking it hopefully
I'll pick it up how do you find your
passion you find your passion by
exploring you find your passion by
trying by saying yes by when you if you
have no idea what you want to do then
you have that's here that should be your
media priority like what are you doing
if you don't know what you want to do
then why are you wasting another week
another month of the year going down a
boring path like your immediate goal
should be to figure out what it is that
you love doing and so you say yes to
everything somebody invites you to
something yes I'm gonna go somebody
invites you to try some new food yes I'm
gonna try that food like you should try
everything once I think everybody should
try being an entrepreneur I think
everybody should try creating YouTube
videos I think everybody should try to
write a book I think everybody should
try and then you see you see in a
low-risk way right to get a taste
because you don't need to eat an entire
Turkey to know if you like Turkey right
like you take a bite of Turkey or butter
tart something like oh that was amazing
and I want to eat that bite again or wow
that sucked
that's terrible right you don't need to
eat a six packs of butter tarts to know
if you like butter tarts or not so
that's what you need to do you take a
little take a little taster of lots of
different things until you find a thing
that
I really like that what's that called
the butter tart mmm I'm gonna eat
another one I want another one give me
another bite
give me another bite and sit you do that
enough you found your passion right
butter tarts and so you want to say yes
to a whole bunch of different things
different opportunities yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes going with an open
mind see if you love it and it's not the
thing that like you have to dedicate the
rest of your life to this thing it's
just I want to go back and do it again
and I would I would you know I don't
know you but I would guess if I go back
to the other question around the how do
I find like-minded people if you haven't
found your passion then you haven't made
it important enough to find your passion
and you haven't put in enough on a daily
basis of activities to go out and try to
find your passion you need to be doing
something on a small scale every day
half an hour to an hour every day to
find your passion test something out
every single day if you're not doing it
then it's not important enough to you
and so put it in the time because life
is not worth building somebody else's
dream like life is so much more than
waking up going to work waiting for
quitting time and then trying to count
down the days until the weekend your
next vacation most people wake up and
they go to a job that they hate every
single day it's crazy to me and there's
nothing wrong with being an employee and
having a job and going somewhere if
that's if that's your calling that's
what you want to do not everybody has to
be an entrepreneur but everybody has the
ability to be great at something
everybody has a passion inside them and
if you don't know what that is it should
be your number one responsibility to go
and find out what that is
good luck jo-ann Evan hello how's your
day going they say happiness is a choice
I couldn't agree more on that but if you
will be required to choose one pain to
sustain what will it be Wow okay well my
day is awesome thank you for asking I
appreciate that jo-ann
if I had to pick one pain to sustain
what will it be the pain that I would
choose is the fear of regret that drives
me the fear of regret the pain of regret
feeling regret
yeah it pushes me to do more to be
better it's easy to get stuck in your
current environment to say okay
everything I've done is great if I look
at me now like things are it's easier to
get comfortable once you start making a
certain amount of money it's easy to
it's easy to be comfortable right you
don't have bill collectors pressuring
you you don't have family pressuring you
you don't have debts or government or
whoever pressuring you it's easy to get
comfortable and so a big thing that
pushes me every day is is regret and I
want it like I don't want it if you gave
me the option to get rid of regret I
wouldn't take it I want I want the fear
of regret
I want it always in me maybe maybe I
just like the pain but that's what I
would pick interesting question next ah
ah shoot oh Sh Evan how does scale the
impossible in one month can be said
about an exam much love from India how
to scale the impossible in one month can
be said about an exam I don't know what
you're really asking if you're trying to
study for an exam in one month and
you're just kind of getting started so
if I were if I were studying if I was
trying to figure out how to finish my
exam in one month I would break down my
own study habits and understand how and
where I work best so as an example when
I was writing my book your one word I
needed I needed to be somewhere else I
don't I don't write really well when I'm
in my office for whatever reason and I
don't I like I like getting out and so I
spent a day a week going to Whole Foods
a local cafe and and and I wrote there
and I said the whole day there and I
shut off all distractions you know
nobody could reach me except my wife and
she knew I was writing and and I
finished my book that's how I did it and
yes I could fight and Sayla I'm gonna
fight through this I'm gonna I'm going
to make it on I'm gonna do it at at my
office because it's just more convenient
and I don't want that weakness and so
I'm gonna fight my way through it
but I also wanted to get the book done
and so play To Your Strengths I also
wrote better when I did once a week
instead of trying to do half an hour in
the morning or an hour and a half in the
morning some people like to do morning
pages and that's where their writing
comes from again like figure out what
the thing is for you so when I was
studying as an example going back to my
university days I found instrumental
music to be great for me to study too I
had man I'm dating myself but I had I
had I had tapes
I had tapes cassette tapes of Phantom of
the Opera and Jurassic Park the
instrumental and I would have those on
repeat for whatever reason the classical
music those those two those two stapes
really helped me focus and concentrate
and I did really well in terms of
absorbing information so I would figure
out what the environment is that's ideal
for you working environment studying
environment you know do you like a dark
hole do you need a brightly lit do you
want to be outside you want to be in a
library or cafeteria like where do you
need to be to get the most out of it and
then how long do you need to study for
at a time can you go eight hours
straight you know do you need to go in
in 90 minute chunks and take a bathroom
break you know do you need to walk
outside every hour just to clear your
head like try to figure out where your
start to drop off and what little micro
activity you can do do you want to study
for 45 minutes you start losing track
great go down do ten push-ups get back
up keep going right that kind of stuff
and then music and food and all the
things that like make you if if you can
figure that stuff out you can create so
much progress in one month it's a ton of
time it's not impossible it's not
impossible to scale you could do it if
you really understand how your body
works and how your mind works it's a
good luck next healing through
inspiration how do we get more sales
well it depends depends on what you're
selling depends if you're going to do it
online offline I'm a big believer more
on the marketing side
in sales I love marketing that leads to
sales I think you need to just like the
last question actually reverse engineer
who you are and then play to your
strengths so as an example I am NOT
great at going door-to-door and
introducing myself I'm not the type a
personality
I don't introduce myself at networking
events my networking events strategy is
be the speaker at the networking event
so that people will come up to me
afterwards or I'll go into the middle of
a room wherever people are hanging out
and I'll take out my phone and I'll just
start making my videos I'll start doing
Instagram applies to people Twitter
applies to people making videos on my
phone and that generates some interest
in who's this guy in the middle of the
room making videos and people recognize
me in the cup and they start a
conversation well I will almost never go
up to somebody say hey I'm having
Comerica what do you do and yes like I
could work on that skill I could get
better at that but I don't want to I
don't want I'm not interested in
improving my weaknesses I want to go
harder on my strengths and so what are
you great at I'm better at marketing and
branding and telling a story then I am
at selling now somebody comes in and you
know is interested in doing something
with me I'm pretty good to be able to
close them but it's way easier when
somebody's coming to you as opposed the
other way around and so I'd be figuring
out where do you shine do you shine and
having conversations do you shine and
being the public speaker at the front
you shine in creating great content you
shine at making videos like figure out
the thing that you can be amazing at and
then just figure out how can that add
value to your customers because there's
a lot of ways to win there's a lot of
ways to make sales and figuring out the
combination of what you love and what
you're great at with what the customer
is interested in what they're gonna pay
attention to that's where you start the
win and bring win more sales good luck a
little a little peace of love how do you
get past a major setback in life any
examples of how you have I've been
Carmichael
so one I'd be looking at what is my
vision what do I want to keep doing what
I want to create what do I want to go
off and and build my life around because
that will be you need to have the
calling you need to have the passion
because that'll that'll get you through
a lot of the tough times the second
thing goes what really helped me was
studying the successes and failures of
all these famous entrepreneurs because I
realized everybody failed like the more
you fail the more you win and the more
you hear that message from different
people in all sorts of different
industries and categories everybody says
the same thing in different words but
there's the same message that you need
to fail along your path to success the
people who fail the most win the most
and so this is just a failure right just
it shifts the perspective the biggest
failure setback for me the hardest time
I had was one when I quit my first
business and I just felt worthless I was
making no money I told my business
partner quit and I woke up the next day
and like I just felt like I couldn't
quit hearing me say that I quit on
something that I cared about and I'm
happy to quit on something I don't care
about but something I cared about in
quitting on it before seen an end result
I couldn't deal with it I couldn't
handle it so I had to go back and find
another way and that led me to learning
about modeling success and that's when
that was the first time I started
looking to successful people and how did
they accomplish what they did and what
can I learn from them and so that really
really really helped me so those two
things have a strong passion for what
you're doing and then recognize that as
normal and that everybody goes through
this and that you just found one way not
to do it and you have to get back on the
horse and do it again the biggest
failure involves quitting after your
first failure
Jerry Heath Evan how would you market a
crypto cryotherapy business I thought
was thinking as got crypto man on the
line there cryotherapy business so
cryotherapy I'm assuming like you have
an actual physical location something
local that people have to come to I
would be looking at who are the people
in my community
who could be strong influencers for me
so I'd be hitting up Instagram is
probably your best bet to find the
people who are posting in a community
snapchat has a really good local feature
now as well and if you look at who's
posting around where I'm at who is
influential and how can I get them to
come in for a session and hopefully like
it right give away a sample in exchange
for some promotion and publicity and get
them to share and so anybody who's
posting in your area you could do an
Instagram pretty easily that that'd be
where I'd be starting I'd be looking at
other local magazines newspapers
influencers that I can get a story
written about me I'd be doing some
education to understand that what is
cryotherapy why it works and along that
lines I've been looking at who could I
partner with not from a business partner
did in terms they own equity in your
company but who would be recommending
cryotherapy because education is really
expensive to educate one at a time this
is a new thing right like I know a
little bit of a crowd of therapy but I'm
not an expert I've never done it myself
and it's not what most people talk about
and so this education has to be done for
you to educate one at a time it's really
hard for you to educate the people who
can then educate for you makes it a lot
easier so why would somebody come to
cryotherapy and then who are the people
who might make referrals for you so
before somebody comes across era P what
are the issues that they have in their
life in their body that they need fixing
and who are they going to before so as
an example a personal trainer do
personal trainers recommend cryotherapy
you know I have a personal trainer we
workout twice a week in my gym if he
told me hey Evan that back issue that
you're having I think it could be solved
through cryotherapy here's a company
that can go do it go check it out guess
what I'm doing I'm gonna go check it out
right if Sean tells me the chicklet
cryotherapy I'm gonna go off and check
out Crowe therapy and so what you need
to do is get to know Sean right in the
Sean's of your community
because if he's recommending you he's
telling dozens hundreds thousands of
people about what you do and it's
complimentary right you're not taking
away his business it's complimentary
right if my back heals faster I can
spend more time doing personal training
right and so those are the people that I
try to be connecting with instead of
trying to go one at a time to the mass
market
good luck
Odin Jordan Belfort or Peter Thiel
depends on what pens on what you want
I'm not a super fan of either them to be
honest but it just depends on what you
want if you're looking at just pure
straight-up salesmanship and learning
sales skills I would go bail for it and
if you're looking for investing if you
know future projection like where the
world is going then
then Peter Thiel but I think you learn
this I think you learn something from
everybody I think I have a problem with
that question period because you should
be able to learn something from
everybody I could learn something from
Belfort and I can learn something from
teal and soon as you do is an either-or
you lose next jet blade jet blade
Barbados how do we really take our jet
pack flight company to new heights jet
pack flight company to new heights so I
don't really know what you're doing they
are going to be kind of selling the
Taurus I know tourism is a huge industry
in Barbados similar to the question
about the cryotherapy I'll be looking at
who can be the right alliance partner
for me so if you're selling to Taurus as
an example right I want to make deals
with the cruise ships
I want to make deal with the travel
agents I want to make deals with the
airline it's like anybody who who is
dealing with tourism you're gonna have
to get a give up a cut to make that
happen
but that's what I wanna I wanna I want
to build up the momentum to get
everybody using my thing if you're not
dealing with tourism's I'd be looking at
who could who could buy multiple
versions of this at the start of
anything I would much rather sell B to B
then B to C because they can put they
could put they can make big orders for
you so instead of selling instead of
thinking who's gonna buy one jetpack
who's gonna buy a hundred who could you
sell a hundred jetpacks to who in the
barbados start local could you sell
hundred jet packs - is it a hotel is it
a business is that the police services
like it see policemen jetting down
chasing after people like who are you
gonna sell a hundred jet packs to and go
and make that sale and then customize it
now he's got to be customized to work
with them and tweaks and features and
all that stuff but much better than
trying to go either way like if you're
going to tourism angle or if you're
going B to B it's way better than trying
to sell B to C one at a time good luck
next crafty be crafty B thank you for
the love she's been sending a lot of
love on an Instagram recently been
spending a lot of time on Instagram so
you guys can show me out there my kids
are both an entertainment and want to
make youtube videos I'm scared to let
them out there
would you let Hayden start his own
channel that was his passion his young
age yeah so first off Hayden you know
you have to be 13 have your own YouTube
channel Hayden is nine so you know
that's that's not possible but I could
do it with him I think I think whatever
people want to do this is going to be
fear around and the answer is not to
just avoid it the answer is to help them
through it because that that I feel is
the the role of a parent and the role of
a leader like somebody wants to do
something there's risk with anything and
you're I see my role is not to say don't
do this because there are risks it's I'm
gonna help you here the risk that I'm
gonna help you go through it if you want
so what are you so afraid of for your
kids to be an entertainment well you
might say the negative comments or the
haters great so help them understand the
mindset of a hater help them understand
how to deal with the hater show them
examples watch videos like if you don't
have the knowledge and content yourself
then research with them like go find
other people talking about how to deal
with haters because the alternative is
the alternative the alternative is they
do it without you they just go off and
don't tell you about it and maybe
they're not old enough yet but like kids
are smart and they will find a way to do
something that they want to so they do
it without you and then they're off in
the world on
trying to deal with these issues that
you know they're gonna face without your
your help right or they're gonna resent
you for the rest of their life because
you told them not to do something and
they actually listened right in either
case is terrible right and so it's it's
same thing around talking to kids about
drugs and alcohol and sex and all this
kind of stuff do you want to leave that
to your teachers to their teachers to do
do you hope that enough is covered in
sex ed class that it gives them the
information that they need right because
people are experimenting a lot earlier
than we think and so whatever fear you
have and this this if we expand this
beyond just parenting now we talk about
people on your team
whatever fear you have for the people
that you are guiding or you are leading
the fear is real but the ultimate goal
of a leader I think is the Train of the
leaders is to help people match their
fears go through their fears to see the
fears that they didn't know we're coming
and help walk them through it instead of
saying no don't do that and saying this
is too big a step for you like what are
you teaching them this is too hard so
don't do it you can't handle this so
don't do it like I would hate to have
that message for at least for me going
to Hayden to say no you can't do this
because you're not ready you can't
handle it you're not you're not good
enough that's that's never gonna happen
every day
you know we end our conversation with
chemicals can do anything and so I try
to live by that next should n Evan is
age matter when you want to start
working on your own what your passion is
I'm 18 and want to be a musician no the
other thing that matters is can you
actually provide some value right and so
you know in theory somebody who's done
40 years of music would be better than
you and would be able to provide more
value than you could ultimately it's
about being able to help somebody said
about be able to move somebody but it's
it's just insane how much you can learn
about something when you're really
passion
dedicated to it if you really wanted to
be an amazing musician and develop your
style you could do that within the next
year whether you're a teen or whether
you're seven or whether you're 45 I've
gone all-in recently on Instagram I've
mentioned it like a couple times now
because it's it's top of mind for me for
the past two to three weeks I've been
really hardcore on Instagram and like I
secretly love the challenge because I
only have it took me like six years to
get the six thousand subscribers or
followers and in a month to get to seven
thousand right but I love that I'm only
at seven thousand you - I've got 1.1
million i has seven thousand is nothing
like joining for the journey we're
starting all over again I love it and I
I digest it everything about Instagram
and I'm applying it in something that I
tried one day like okay we're throwing
that away we're doing this tomorrow and
we're throwing that away and that all
sucked here we go we're doing this
against like iteration iteration
iteration iteration testing testing
testing I was on a call last week with a
Instagram marketing guy this is what he
does his business and I'm keeping up
like some of the tools that I'm using he
hadn't heard of before some of the
strategies that I'm applying you know
hehe like like this is what people are
doing is like I'm I'm talking the same
language as him and he's been doing this
for however long and I've been doing it
for two weeks but because I'm interested
because if you read a text book to
memorize something for a test most of it
flies out of your head the next day but
when you actually care about something
it sticks because you understand how
relates to these other things that
you're trying to do
and so if you want to be a musician
you're 18 you've won like tons of
musicians have done it younger than you
has nothing to do with age what matters
is that you can create something that
people will care about so good luck
Salima Evan have you ever suffered from
winter blues uh have I ever suffered
from winter blues so first off I'm in
Canada we have winter winter is real
here you know my my both sets of my
grandparents would fly to Florida every
year for half the years to avoid the
winter months
I know that I ever had really winter
blues I prefer the summer than the
winter but especially last year I think
it's just finding a way to to make the
winter win for you this part of it of
the gratitude like you don't appreciate
the summer unless you have the winter
but I started enjoying the winter a lot
more first when I picked up snowboarding
which I guess was four years ago five
years ago something like that and then I
started paying attention how much
snowfall is coming down like what can we
get can we go hit the slopes can we do
this
and as my snowboarding interests died
down last year I got into trying wim HOF
and the the cold showers and the
breathing and that really helped me not
get sick which was awesome because used
to get sick all the time
and part of it is cold showers but I
also like I like going cold outside and
so it's it's an easy way to always have
a cold option as opposed to being it
being you know super hot outside all the
time so I think finding something that
you can do and enjoy about the winter is
is helpful but I don't I've never really
had winter blues where like I can't wait
to get away I can't wait for summer you
know winter sucks if honestly if that
was me I would I would leave like if I
couldn't find a way to to make winter
work for me and it caused such a
negative distraction of my life I would
do with my grandparents a like I would
go to I would go to Florida for half the
year or fly somewhere else to be there
for half the year if you find the thing
that is causing that level of toxicity
for you like winter socks or my parents
or you know my best friend or whoever it
is like it's causing so much pain and
negativity in your life then you either
have to find a way to make it work for
you or you have to abandon it and find
like go do something else be around
positive people being around being a
summer hot place and it's possible it's
totally doable you just have to decide
to do it ah next you're at a bite yota
bite yottabyte hello from Panama I love
it never been to Panama one day what
would your what would be
advice for an interview with an
organization that deals with mixed
opinions on social problems how to make
your opinion sound neutral so one I
would I would never try to appear
neutral on something that I wasn't
actually neutral about I think that has
to be your starting point so you may not
be hard on one side of things so
whatever social issue you're dealing
with you may not come down hard on one
side but you're you're open to learning
from both sides I think you can come
down and say here's you have to have a
natural curiosity for this thing and
here's what I'm thinking here's kind of
where I stand right now but I'm I'm open
to be moved I want to understand because
I think even the people on one side who
are hard one side if they just thought
listen I'm trying to understand the
other side I think that makes for a
great conversation I think the problem
is these people think that they're right
and these people think that they're
right and they both think the others are
idiots and then you just get conflict
where if you can understand the other
perspective you may not agree with it
you mean I think it's the right thing to
do but you can at least understand them
like this is not a terrible human being
on the other side here there's still a
person they still have wants and dreams
and hopes just to have we have a
difference of values around something
that's okay so I would I would try to
either find issues that I didn't have an
opinion on yet and I'm curious about and
then bring both parties in or if I had
some kind of opinion on it I would lead
with that and not try to be impartial
when I'm not I just have a problem with
with not being me I have a problem
people who are not authentic I don't
have to agree with you but don't come
off as something fake right
so I try to find a way to make it
authentic like maybe that's you're on
one side and you kind of in the middle
but you're still on one side and you
bring on the counterpart to you who can
ask the other questions they're on the
other side but in the middle right and
then you're bringing on the hardliners
to try to understand them right to
balance it out just try to do something
that would be authentic to you I think
if
you did that that's what you will start
to win I think if you can get people
from opposite sides to understand each
other or if you have an opinion on
something and you want to try to learn
from the other the other side and just
get their perspective I think that's how
you actually create great content I
think when you start pretending to be
impartial when you're not I think you
lose I think people can see through it I
think it's BS and I think you lose good
luck ah
Kwami at evan and at Lily Lily Lily's in
the house she's the one word coach I
love it when when setting long-term
goals should I also plan the steps in
between that lead up to those goals
is that what short term goals are should
my goal would be clear and find out so
you know Lily will probably leave her
two cents in a chat you can ask her
questions too if you guys are there my
take is maybe radically different than
most
I like having one big long-term never
gonna happen
mission so it started with I wanted to
help a billion entrepreneurs it's
evolved to I want to solve the world's
biggest problem which is untapped human
potential like it's never gonna happen
it's not possible it's always more
potential right this is this is life
it's a life goal it's a
multi-generational thing like it's never
gonna happen just me and I like that and
then I set up really kind of micro goals
like what am I gonna be doing in the
next three months and that's what I
focus on I don't have five-year goals as
soon as I said a five-year goal it's
like whoa how can I make that happen in
in five months instead of five years I
think about what I've done in the past
five years it wasn't it was never part
of my goals my goal five years ago was
not to have two books out my goal five
years ago was not to have a million
subscribers on YouTube
my goal five years ago was not to do a
weekly show with you guys
so I'm I'm maybe I'm just terrible at
long-term planning I think as soon as
you have a long term plan if you have a
five-year plan it's like what are you
waiting on let's go like make that
happen way sooner I can't predict where
I'm gonna be in five years so I like
having a forever mission it's like a
driving force but how I execute it will
change right untapped human potential
how do you do that well I don't know I'm
figuring it out I'll let you know as I
start coming up with some goals right
and then basically really my day-to-day
I'm looking at three months out like
what am i doing for the next three
months sometimes as far as a year but
really it's like the next three months
for me so that's what I got for you good
luck next Gaghan ray Evan how to make
the best use of social networks how do
we use them how do we use them when
you're staying when you're still
starting with your work and how can we
manage your time between work and other
works so there's a lot in there one
picked in that work that you can win on
pick the network that has the best
combination of everything that you love
doing in terms of creating content don't
don't try to do all of them at the
beginning you won't have enough time
you'll blow your brains out you will
you'll just feel stretched and you'll
create crap across all of them right
like if you try to make a video go on
Twitter and Instagram and Pinterest
and a neigh-neigh in you're gonna you're
gonna get frustrated get tired and
create garbage across all of them so
pick the one that means the most to you
that where your audience is and what you
are great at doing so I like YouTube
because I like making videos I like the
Q&A I like I would much rather answer
questions like this then write out a
response but you may be different that's
okay so find the one that fits your
style best and then create daily content
every single day I would honestly want
you to do three times a day but start
with one because when when I say three
times a day people freaked out
when I say one people honest is still
freaked out but one a day you can find
time
it's just scheduling the time to make it
a priority I had a friend entrepreneur
yesterday he wanted he wanted strategy
and how to grow an Instagram I great
you're talking to the right guy now I'm
loving Instagram I'm all-in on Instagram
and he was talking I told him okay you
gotta do it daily go to daily post a
daily videos like every day how do you
do that every day like what are you
talking about man
like you could sit down go home in the
afternoon and plan out 30 different
posts 30 different quotes or expressions
or opinions you have and find pictures
of them and you'd have content for the
next 30 days like you could do that this
afternoon
people just get in their own way and so
there's there's pros and cons to each
Network but in terms of starting from
the beginning I'd be again just looking
at what is the network that means the
most to you and then finding the hacks
to win so as an example snapchat
snapchat has a feature called
our story there's my story in our story
when you go our story it gets featured
in your local story in in the local
community so when I post at Toronto dine
salsa it posts to the we're in a mall
called Empress walk it pose to the
Empress walk story it gets picked up
sometimes it get featured in the Toronto
story gets featured in the Canada story
that's great that's a chance it's so
location based that is a chance every
day for for somebody to win right like
as a newbie you have a chance to win
because it doesn't matter if if I have
the biggest following on snapchat in the
world or not you're not in my city right
so you can always win you can always get
people who are close to you consuming
your content and if it's good which your
stuff has to be good if you want to
ultimately win then it'll be you'll
reach a city level and then state level
and maybe national level so that's a
little hack on snapchat Instagram has
its own local functions and so picked in
that pick the network first and then
understand it create daily content for
it and then just find the hack so you
can win on a local basis as a small
creator getting started
another quick one Instagram very hashtag
culture focused the hashtags like if
you're posting content with the hashtag
motivation you're never going to win
like you're never gonna stand out
because there's five million posts
around motivation so you start with
smaller hashtags if I was pure startup
I'd be looking at hashtags with under
ten thousand posts and target those and
then create daily content until I'm
winning until I'm always showing up for
those and then go to between ten and
twenty five and then twenty five and
fifty and then 50 to 100 right 100 to
250 right you just keep going up that's
what I'm skin with my content with my
hashtags I'm dominating a lot of the
small hashtags I'm a guy with 7,000
followers right Joe and Marjorie I'm not
pushing it hard on my videos to say go
follow me because I wanted I liked you
organic growth and so I was doing the
smaller hashtags and I looked at one
this morning
I like 5,000 posts or something like I
have every I'm every top post in the
5,000 out of the 5,000 and so I think
okay we're killing that one if I'm if
I'm every post in this hashtag every top
post we got a killer I'm gonna move on
to something else and so we're up in the
competitiveness on each one now
something like believe might be too
competitive for me right now but it's
part of my brain and so we're we're
using belief but find the one that fits
the best for you and then understand the
tactics and the hacks that as a beginner
you can use to get going but don't let
the lack of a plan prevent you from
getting started now like just go you can
create daily content across any platform
if you really wanted to you can do it
and the more you do it the better you
get and where you're gonna win good luck
next gray Watson been thinking about
crowdfunding you have any insights how
can I easily make people sign up even
before the complete set up so the thing
that nastain about crowdfunding is you
can't just rely on the crowdfunding
website to get the dollars coming in you
have to do a full-on marketing campaign
to get it to lift like you're not gonna
put it up on Kickstarter and hit the
home page and instantly get funded right
so you have to do a lot of work in in
the setup for it so I've been looking at
one you need a great product description
of what you're gonna be building to in
an amazing video do not do a
crowdsourced campaign without an amazing
video 3 you got to have your tier set up
so that this value that they're getting
every step along the way whether they're
giving you $1 $10 $100 $1,000
there's tons of value along the way next
to be looking at I need to build a list
of everybody that I know that will
support me so that when I go press
launch I'm gonna get sales coming in
next
I'm building a list of all the
influencers in the industry and I'll
find it online who have something to say
who have a relevant message and I want
to let them know about it and that it's
launching all of this before you ever
even launch right so if you have an
entrepreneur related thing I'm the guy
to talk to if you have a butter tart
thing I still may be the guy to talk to
but if you have makeup products like
don't talk to me I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna be able to lift your campaign at
all and so all of that has to it's it's
not easy if you dissect the campaigns
that win it's not easy it's a full-on
campaign it's a ton of work to line it
up it's great in that once it gets lift
it'll be promoted more and you'll get
more opportunities to get featured it's
also great in that you're not giving up
any equity in your company and you're
not it's not a debt it's not a loan that
you have to pay back
it's pre-orders it's great it's all it's
all money for you right but it's not
easy it's a ton of work to set up those
successful campaigns and so go through
those steps that I gave you and it'll
hopefully give you the boost that you
need
guys thank you for the love it's crazy
how quickly an hour flies by I know
there's a ton of questions that keep
coming in Lily saying she's bringing
butter tarts on Monday no Lily Monday is
not my cheat day Saturday
I need butter tarts on Saturday make
sure they're good anyway if you have
questions hopefully we'll do this again
next Thursday another AMA thank you guys
so much the love it's noon for me
whatever times when it is for you
remember there's still there's still
time for you to do something awesome
today like don't don't let the energy
from this lead to you just falling back
into your regular day like today is
important make you can't create
something in the next X number of hours
you have before you go to bed that you
want to show your grandkids stop
sleeping on your life let's go happy
Thursday guys continue to believe and
whatever your one word is much loved see
you soon